yeah thanks a lot for the kind
introduction
I already realized that maybe for my
next talk I should pick a shorter title
to make it a little bit easier for you
so cool to have you all here then let's
talk about bread I would say so bird is
a language model that got published
around a year ago already and the goal
of bird in the first phase which I would
call pre-training here is to learn as
much about language in general as
possible so how does that work how do we
learn about language in general we take
an input sentence like the one you can
see here Berlin is the capital and
largest city of Germany we feed it to
the model but we randomly mask some of
the input words so in this example the
words is largest and off and with that
we then ask the model to predict which
words should fill the missing gaps this
training procedure works completely
unsupervised we can generate as much
training data as we want from simple raw
text just take the text mask some words
and use the words with masks as training
objective unlabeled text we basically
have enough so bird was trained on
really big corpora for example the
entire dump of Wikipedia which is quite
a bit of text I would say and this
training of objective of masking some
words and let the model predict what
words we're missing sounds quite simple
but it was one of the major novelties in
the bird paper why because when we asked
her to predict the word large
it can use the context on the left side
of the word as well as the context on
the right side of the word to make this
prediction so the the learning is
bi-directional this is one of the key
concepts the B umberto also stands for
bi-directional previous language models
were usually trained in a way that they
had to predict the next the next the
next word of a sentence and therefore
they only had access to the context on
the left the representation that bird
learns using this training procedure
appear to to be really good
representations to use the pre trent
model for a range of downstream tasks so
for example once we're done with the pre
training phase we can move over to the
fine-tuning phase and train for example
classification model we would use
exactly the same model as before we only
replace the last layer sober does not
predict the mask words but a simple
class label and then we can train on a
little bit of label data to complete
this task classification is just one
possible use case so bird can be used
for many different NLP tasks another
example would be named entity
recognition so we predict attack for
each of the input tokens and thereby
find for example persons and locations
in text so if we compare this free
training and fine tuning face free
training takes up most of the time so we
can easily spend a week on a on an
entire cluster free training but we
might need less than one hour on a
single GPU to master a fine tuning in
addition to that many pre trained models
got open-source together I was the code
so in the beginning a year ago there was
only an English but model
but by now for example there's also a
multilingual model that can understand
or that at least was trained on a
hundred four different language so
there's a high chance that that your
language was part of this list the more
dealing were birds bird even speaks
Bavarian that this transfer in general
works from from pre-training
representation to the fine-tuning task
has been shown so Burt achieved really
good results on a range of benchmark
data sets so how does it work how do we
get from the totals to the embedding so
here you can see kind of an architecture
sketch of birds so for each totin we
have an embedding so a vector of float
numbers and these we feed into a
sequence of transformer blocks each
transformer block has a self attention
part and a feed forward part and in a
smaller version of bird we have 12 of
these blocks and in a larger version we
have 24 so layer by layer we kind of
built up a contextualized representation
of each input token I'm not going to go
into more detail how exactly the
transformer block blocks work because in
this talk today I mainly want to point
your attention to the early stage of the
model so the embedding layer and each of
these embeddings you can see here
consists of three components so the
first component for every word is a word
embedding so there's an embedding
representation for the word city and
city and in idea any other occurrence in
the text would get the same word
embedding then second there's a position
embedding so City in this input sequence
is token number six and for all other
input sequences token number six would
get the same position embeddings per
needs position embeddings because it's
based on the transformer architecture so
there's no concept of word order
incorporated by design so a recurrent
Network for example would read word by
word
that's not how to transform my work
works the transformer needs these
position embeddings to make sense of of
the order and then there's a third
component which is called segment
embedding that's not so important for us
today but basically for tasks where you
have multiple inputs so for example
question answering you have a question
and you have a paragraph and these two
things question and paragraph would get
different segments embedding so bird can
distinguish what's the question now
what's the paragraph so up until here
this part may sound familiar to people
who maybe read the bird paper or read
related articles but I feel that less
resources actually talk about how to get
from the raw text to totems in the first
place so there's two steps and the first
step we just take the sentence like he's
going home here and we would split by
whitespace and we would separate all the
punctuation symbols so you can see how
this works here so this is the easiest
step and then there's a second step
which is where please tokenization so
for each word we got from the first step
yeah we would we would further split
these up if needed so if you look at the
he's going home example again going was
split into two parts so the verb stem go
and the typical English suffix ing this
kind of example sentences sentences of
used to visualize how word pieced
organization works but I actually feel
that this can be a little bit misleading
because it's important to understand
that the tokenizer doesn't know anything
about grandma the only thing it does is
it takes a word and it's blitzes the
word until we end up with tokens that
are all known known means they are part
of a vocabulary list and this vocabulary
list gets created and completely
data-driven ways so this is nothing
language-specific and doesn't take into
account any yeah any grammatical rules
for example so the vocabulary list
actually gets created before we even
pre-trained but it gets created based on
a big text corpus which in this case
would be the pre-training corpus and we
add the most common words and word
pieces to this vocabulary list so that
we can tokenize the given pre-training
corpus with as few tokens as possible
[Music]
yeah this this list is of course limited
in practice so for the English word
model we have around 30,000 tokens in
that list for the multilingual model
it's more than 100,000 but still in
multilingual case this listens to fit
words from over 100 languages yeah so
what happens to words that are not part
of this list especially if they were not
part of the pre-training corpus I show
you two German examples here that got
tokenized by the multilingual bird
tokenizer and the other words as a
translation as sunlight and recommended
and they get split in two completely
arbitrary parts so if you if I look at
these examples as a native speaker I
would say this doesn't make any sense
[Music]
yeah and my intuition would be if I see
that that is gonna be quite difficult
for the model to understand the meaning
of such a word if if it is chunked
two three or even four different pieces
okay so that's that's basically how it
works and when I dived a little bit
deeper into the topic and realized this
this basically the issues I see with
that so the first one I already
mentioned this vocabulary list is fixed
and it's fixed during the pre-training
face
so basically words that are common on
let's say Wikipedia made it into this
list and once you fine-tune on your own
data which might have completely a
different different kind of language
very remain specific then it's not
possible to add these words afterwards I
mean impossible of course is a hard word
but as long as you use let's say that
the default implementations that are
available online there's it's not
planned that you add words to the
vocabulary like later on in case you use
the multilingual model it's also good to
know that real language is
underrepresented yeah and as we've
already seen on the last slide so if
your text contains a lot of vocabulary
words they get chunked into a lot of
word pieces which increases the overall
sequence links of course which brings us
to the second point the sequence or the
amount of tokens that bird can process
in one go is limited and it's limited
because as we've seen before the
position embeddings are learned so if
you were download a free training bird
model there's position embeddings for
512 toes if we have more than 512 total
myths and there's no no embedding and
therefore it can't be processed so if if
you wanted to learn dependencies that
that's read longer than like over to an
over 512 toes it's it's not possible to
do and in combination with the first
issue so if you have a lot of other
vocabulary
and let's say each word gets polka nice
into three tokens two to three then
maybe 512 tokens means you can only look
at 200 words at one time that's maybe
not too much so up until here has been
theory now when I realized this I was
wondering if the default bird is a good
option for for me to use for my work and
I was or I was wondering if it's better
to basically train my own bird from
scratch I did some experiments on that
and I want to share the findings with
you but first for you to be able to put
that into context I'm gonna yeah give
you some background about the data
I work was so at omnes we deal with
insurance documents so for example with
invoices and I'm responsible for
extracting information from these
documents so in terms of NLP I'm doing
entity recognition the documents we have
are usually in German and they of course
contain a lot of domain-specific words
like super specific article name stood
where repaired in this invoice next
point is that often we don't even start
with the text already but we start
earlier with just a scan
so from the image we have to first run
optical character recognition OCR and
this OCR algorithms can of course do
make mistakes so and and all might be
recognized as a zero on L might be
recognized as a one um you can imagine
that this is a big problem for the word
piste organization because if you have a
completely unexpected character in the
middle of a word then the residing word
pieces will be very different then we
also have a lot of numeric value
so phone numbers for example will be
always out of vocabulary so yeah and
last but not least if if we cannot
process an entire page in one goal then
we need to split it somewhere and since
we have no proper sentence structure
like no normal text it's hard to know
where to split the text okay so
basically I tried to compare three
different things option number one is
the easiest just download the
multilingual model and find unit on the
inverse that I just described you the
second option
I thought about was to set at least the
language correct and basically followed
the pre-training that was done for
original bird but just do it for German
so let's say download the German
Wikipedia train my own general German
model and then find you in this on the
invoices we have so comparing option one
and two I would I would expect that the
German model performs better because the
data is yeah I mean the the pre-training
and fine-tuning data's at least a little
bit more similar and then there's option
number three and this is a little bit
out of competition I have to admit so
this was my attempt to really start from
scratch and implement a version of word
that is really suited for my use case
and maybe not that general so I tried to
train on on domain data from the
beginning I gave up on the concept of
word piece and bearings and used fast
text embeddings instead which we already
do and usually got good results with
that and in order to keep memory in one
time somewhat in hand I reduced the
number of layers and the hidden size
compared to the original model so here's
the results and against my duration the
German model did not
perform better than the multilingual one
so I didn't train the German model
myself in the end I was lucky that the
people from deep set AI here in Berlin
were faster and they open sourced their
version of Bert and they also published
a really interesting article about this
free training project and their results
so it's really interesting I put the
link here in the food I have a look and
they said that they needed around nine
days on a TPU to pre pre train that
model that's of course a lot more effort
than just let's say download the
multilingual model in terms of
fine-tuning there's no difference just
the memory of the multilingual model is
it takes up a little bit more memory
because it has a larger vocabulary list
I also had a look at into how many
tokens each word gets split on average
and I was a little bit surprised to see
that there's not even such a big
difference for between English
multilingual and German at least on my
data so maybe there were just too many
phone numbers and prices that get
organised kind of language independent
property and then in the last column you
can see they attempt to to implement my
custom model the performance is worse
but it's also nice to see that it's not
that far off I spend more or less one
1/2 days of free training on a single
GPU and for fine tuning it took a bit
longer I actually took on to converge to
a good performance yeah that was more or
less an hour but yeah I could really
reduce the GPU memory compared to the
original size per model and since I used
fast text embeddings instead of the word
piece embeddings each word was directly
taking us at home not further tokenized
oh yeah just to give you I mean these
were the results on my data deep-set
also did experiments on multiple
downstream tasks
they concluded that in four out of five
cases the German model was actually
better then we're dealing women so
here's my final slide for you to reflect
should you train your own red model if
you ask me I would rather say no okay
that's basically it thanks for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
we have time for questions hi excellent
resonation
I have a doubt does Burt process and
understand languages that's written from
right to left like Hebrew Arabic and
stuff or is it only for languages that's
applicable from left to right I mean
since birth basically doesn't read the
text in order like a recurrent Network
but all text at the same time and then
the the attention scores determine how
much towards influence each other
I think it shouldn't matter if the text
is right-to-left since you also mention
it's bi-directional yes so it should not
be a problem good think thank you for
the presentation one quick question why
was your baseline you come prepared but
did you have another model that you try
before for Cup for the task that you
show oh yes so if you look at these
results training or like kind of also
standard by lsdm architecture was giving
me 76% of f1 score so yeah
do you know what's the language split in
the multilingual model from Bert so for
example like are they mostly
indo-european languages and if so what
percentage and what other language
families are in that language model okay
so it's not only European languages so
there's also there's also Chinese
there's also Japanese there's also I
don't know but basically the way they
selected the languages was by taking the
hundred four biggest Wikipedia's so
every every language that has kind of a
lot of articles on Wikipedia was
included if you google for that list
there's also there's also a list of all
languages that that were included there
another question have you tried making
your own custom bird model which is not
an indo-european language no because
yeah I mean as I said like at work I
mainly deal with German documents so
until now I never had a chance to to
work on on other languages hi thanks for
the really nice talk so you mentioned
one drawback here about the sequence
length which which was around fight will
sub tokens I mean if if it's right so
did you not run into this problem
considering its insurance documents and
assuming we run into those problems
which we are how did you like how do you
propose to go about it okay so what I
did in this this case was kind of this
the simplest and most stupid option to
just feed 512 totin and then do a cut
and fit the next and this is probably
not not the best option so I guess what
you could also do is kind of have a
sliding window and then always use the
prediction for that sliding window that
had the most context forward this you
could do but yeah I mean one thing I did
was just implement my own version and
there you can increase the sequence
length of course it's just like if you
use the pre trend model then this is
what
you get yeah so you mentioned that the
step before so these scores are for the
the insurance documents correct and so
before that you actually read scans with
no see our model yes what was the
underlying form of the OCR model like
how much did you lose cuz I imagine you
can't get 100% here if the OCR model is
actually you mean if you already have
mistakes or nausea yeah I didn't
evaluate Oceanus takes so basically I
I've had the text as is so if there are
mistakes there are mistakes and then I
checked if the model picks up these
words anyway so yeah I didn't I didn't
compute the percentage of like cause II
errors in the text Thanks hello Mariana
well my name is Mariano and yes nice
presentation I really liked it and I was
wondering so in your experience him when
doing well I'm not I didn't get what was
the task you were trying to achieve in
the in this experiment yes but by
looking at if you had the chance to look
at the errors you were having like your
machine oerf one imagine false positives
false negatives what were the kind of
errors that was doing the most in all
cases just if you had the chance at
least okay so so for part number one the
task I was doing is named entity
recognition so for each word I would
predict attack which then results in
extracted entities so for the invoices I
extracted names for example addresses
the total price everything you can
imagine that is on there i I didn't have
a chance or much of a chance yet to look
at the predictions you're right that
would be interesting but I'm afraid I
cannot tell you too much about that at
that stage
can it be that your fast text embeddings
actually filtered out your
domain-specific language because fastest
texting Spelling's were done again on
some general German language I guess and
since you had your domain-specific
language that didn't occur there could
it be that it got filtered out I so good
question actually so by fast X
embeddings
I mean that I trained my own fast X
embeddings on my domain data so I didn't
just any any pre trained general fasiq
subheadings yeah so they contained
domain knowledge and how did you deal
with the numbers did you filter them out
or did you somehow transform them so
that's that's a really good question so
if anyone is dealing with numbers and
wondering how to embed them I want to
talk to you so for now I just kept the
numbers as is this is probably not the
best option I've seen what people also
often do is just replace each number
with zero so you only end up with the
pattern kind of but then how you're
distinguished between the date and the
invoice number like the format and
zeroes might be the same so for this
experiment I just kept the numbers as is
without any modification do we have any
people in the room who are working with
numbers please we have time for two more
questions
hi so I was wondering if you also tried
for I mean you did your custom training
from scratch right maybe like one option
that could work will be further
pre-training yeah like multilingual or
German Bert on your custom data set and
I'll find unique you consider it I was
yeah I mean I didn't do it actually but
yeah I've heard about this option well
what what basically kept me from doing
it was that the issues I explained so
the fixed vocabulary and the fixed
sequence
don't get solved by that so I mean of
course like you can incorporate some
domain knowledge into the into the
language model but it doesn't update
your vocabulary list and it doesn't add
more physicians than you already have
but yeah that's that's a good good point
there's a good thing to try if you want
to try out put a last question over here
first of all I think that your custom
bird does pretty well considering that
it's a smaller model with three
gigabytes instead of nine gigabytes and
what was it 1.5 days training time so I
think that's that's a very good result
actually maybe you mixed some hyper
parameters for example using fast text
embeddings instead of word piece
tokenization and I would think or maybe
what's what's your how do you see it
what organization could actually handle
yes OCR arrows better than fast text and
pairings don't you think that's the case
I'm not sure to be honest this was more
of a practical consideration also
because with the fastest embedding for
each word I get one embedding it's not
that I split the word into four parts
and then getting am getting embedding
for each so that the choice of fast X
was mainly also a practical one if this
is better compared to the web piece
embedding I'm yeah as I said I'm not so
sure but it would be be interesting to
find out I'm just afraid
it's like split into too many pieces if
if the words contain mistakes and
therefore are not in the vocabulary
anymore thank you for your question
for your questions and let's thank
Mariana again for her wonderful talk